[Musique]
c'est ce qu'on appelle un dérapage
l'humoriste gaëtan mathis gaëtan mathis
cas étant mathis alors qu'il récusait
moore progresse dans les sondages le
jeune maurice gaëtan bâtisse a décidé de
faire une blague de très mauvais goût
sur les réseaux sociaux si j'avais une
machine à voyager dans le temps je
bloquerai le bataclan pour la soirée du
13 novembre 2015 afin d'y organiser une
soirée rencontre entre eric zemmour et
son public une blague qui fait
directement référence aux attentats
djihadistes survenu en 2015 un texte qui
a provoqué l'indignation honnêtement
c'est tout à fait scandaleux d'avoir
tenu ce type de propos si l'humoriste a
tenu à son excuse et dans la foulée il
semblerait que j'ai fait une blague qui
m'a légèrement dépassé le cas du point
virgule dans lequel il est en
représentation en ce moment a préféré
suspendre ces deux prochaines dates pour
éviter tout débordement et a tenu à
condamner ces propos je condamne
fermement évidemment les propos de
gaëtan mathis qui sont extrêmement
malheureux alors attentats du 13
novembre faut-il boycotter l'humoriste
gaëtan mathis après sa blague sur eric
des mois
déjà merci gaëtan est là c'est que ça
doit pas être simple voilà on sait voilà
que c'est pas que c'est compliqué de
venir en direct ici s'expliquer je
suppose que vous avez dû passer un week
end compliqué
gaëtan des gestes que vous regrettez
cette vanne comme vous l'avez dit oui
bah c'est une vanne en vrai j'ai une
vanne est ce que je suis content du
résultat non ce n'était pas du tout le
résultat espéré en vrai je pense que la
connerie de cette blague c'est que
j'étais aux toilettes j'avais mon
téléphone j'ai écrit ce truc je pars
jouer je la fais sur scène les gens se
marrent et ma connerie c'est de l'avoir
figé à l'écrit est mis sur les réseaux
sociaux comme si c'était un cahier de
brouillon alors que on sait ce que vous
disiez avant les réseaux sociaux c'est
tout sauf un cahier de brouillon et en
vrai c'est parti c'était une fois que
c'était parti ça a été un déferlement en
t'écrivant tu t'es pas dit qu'elle
pouvait choquer parce que en fait c'est
ça c'est ce que tu me lis et tu t'es tu
l'a écrit et après tu l'as fait sur
scène du crédit sur scène s'est passée
c'est ça en fait bah
il ya une machine à remonter dans le
temps je trouvais ça moi ça me faisait
rire
c'est là que les gens ont rigolé dans
ton public où j'avais fait deux fois sur
zone d'aucfer les gens se sont marrés en
vrai moi je trouvais ça marrant dans ma
tête voilà ça va être mon style de ce
que je fais
est ce qu'aujourd'hui si j'avais eu une
machine à voyager dans le temps et que
j'aurai vu le merdier que cette blague a
fait et ce que je la referais je suis
pas certain alors hein on beaucoup de
gens sur les réseaux sociaux bien sûr
ton dit à juste titre que les familles
des victimes peuvent être extrêmement
heurté comme tu l'as dit c'est pas tout
à fait pareil de faire une bactérie dans
un spectacle et de l'écrire sur les
réseaux sociaux parce que il ya des gens
qui n'ont rien demandé qui se retrouve
en face d'un d'une vanne voilà qui peut
les choquer qui peut les blesser c'est
ça en fait aussi kéké après on fait plus
de blagues les chaînons ouais mais sur
les réseaux c c'est vrai qu'il faut
faire à ses attentes et où je dois faire
un grand moment de notre histoire mais
alors gaëtan je veux dire c'est ça rien
avoir en fait parce que c'est vrai que
sur scène les gens font la démarche de
venir tous loi devrait donc ils disent
on a fait la démarche je suis assez
d'accord sur les réseaux sociaux les
passe mieux sur scène sur les réseaux
sociaux deux ans et c'est très compliqué
ta conscience de ça que tu as pu heurter
des familles de victimes
j'ai conscience j'ai reçu aussi des
messages de gens qui ont été d'accord
victimes rescapées de ces attentats et
qui ont dit bah moi ça m'a fait rire
enfin tout ça que moi les attentats je
suis comme tous les parisiens je pense
que j'ai été vraiment traumatisé par sa
j'ai pas fais partie de ceux qui sont
partis prendre des selphy en terrasse le
lendemain parce que j'avais peur le
concert suivant que j'ai fait il arriver
plusieurs mois plus tard j'ai passé la
soirée à côté d'une issue de secours
tous âges avaient peur moi c'est ma
manière à moi d de faire aussi évacuer
son stress donc il y en a qui pleurent
il y en a qui font autre chose moi je
fais des blagues correspondent à la
monstruosité du monde en vrai cette
blague je les fait sur un compte
facebook qui a 3000 follow de gens dont
ils suivent sur une story un stack ya à
peine 2000 follow ce que de ceux qui me
connaissent et donc c'est aussi ça va
dans mon univers en fait honte a
reproché de faire un appel au meurtre ou
encore l'apologie du terrorisme
qu'est-ce que tu réponds à sa ba les
machines à remonter le temps je pense
pas que ça existe donc je crois qu'il ya
même pas lieu tu ressens vois pas les
gens qui disent à qui et interpellent
pour ça non les mêmes en fait j'ai même
plus envie de juger la blague
aujourd'hui ces mêmes tuez moi si je la
regrette tu l'as regrette vraiment c'est
est-ce que tu la fais pas ce que je
regrette c'est ce que j'aimerais savoir
j'ai vraiment guéri est-ce que tu
regrettes parce que c'est une mauvaise
blague qui t'a apporté beaucoup dans
merde ou est-ce que tu regrettes la
blague on n
la blague en fait
ce que je disais elle n'est pas faite
pour être postée sur internet mais la
blague en mnq l'ablette pas ça avec ce
que je fais c'est moi je joue en rien à
la réalité du monde aussi horrible
qu'elle soit et moi je fais ça je pense
que c'est aussi un truc raid français
boris vian avait fait la java de la
bombe atomique
brassens a tenu des propos monstrueux
moi mon personnage célébrer un gentil
qui fait des trucs méchant je pense pas
ce que je regrette la à l'heure qu'il
est c'est que ça soit emballé je
regrette de tués est au point virgule là
ce soir je l'arrêté au point virgule et
plus haut point virgule alors voilà ce
que donc la salle de spectacle donc le
point virgule pour l'instant dont ils
sont fait agresser il a donc cassé la
vitrine il a reçu des menaces de mort
j'ai reçu des menaces de mort de
harcèlement d'appel au suicide on a dû
porter plainte aujourd'hui en fait je
suis pas là que en tant qu'humoriste je
suis là en tant que papa compagnon qui
dit là ça m'a échappé est ce que c'est
de l'humour irresponsable est ce que
j'avais idée de la température du pays
quand j'ai fait cette blague moi je
pense qu'en fait au fond j'ai reçu des
tonnes de menaces de mort très saint amé
c'est oui oui genre quoi une multitude
je m'en suis un peu préservé mais du
coup c'est l'avocat qui s'en occupent
mais demande le dossier chaud
suffisamment chaud pour que mon adresse
soit sorti mon adresse physique et je
peux plus dormir chez moi là d'accord
donc là tu dors pas chez toi et moi donc
est ce que je regrette la blague elle
m'a un peu échappé j'en conviens
qu'est-ce qui attaque là ça a tout
changé complètement ce week-end ça a
changé d'avis en fait c'est un truc de
fou ah mais le paon si c'est pour le
buzz j'ai perdu le point virgule en fait
ça fait huit ans que je fais des blagues
ça fait trois ans que j'ai envie que je
nourris ma famille avec lui entre point
virgule c'est une fierté immense c'est
vraiment la salle dans laquelle je
voulais rentrer depuis des années j
étais deux fois par semaine je faisais
mon spectacle mon spectacle parle pas du
tout ça en vérité c'est un spectacle qui
parle de de progressisme toute une
réflexion sur le confinement tout ça et
j'ai perdu ça j'ai mis des collègues de
cette salle dans une situation
compliquée je suis avec
ma femme mes de nos enfants c'est qu'est
ce qui t'as ta vie ta femme ban soutient
lé pa femmes de la blague d'accord allez
pas fan mais bon j'ai une femme
merveilleuse qui me soutient laurent
eric zemmour il a réagi à cette bague en
marge d'un déplacement en corse il
trouve ça ignoble et scandaleux regardez
leurs actionnaires c'est un ami de
yassine belattar je crois ce ce grand
démocrate ce grand tolérant c'est des
gens qui ne supportent pas que les
français veulent rester français et que
la france veut y rester la france je ne
me laisserai pas intimider par des gens
qui me menace je pense c'est ignoble
c'est évidemment scandaleux mais tous
les français jugeront ils sauront qui
est à l'origine des tensions ils sauront
qui est violent ils sauront qu'ils
menacent de mort ce n'est jamais moi moi
je ne me lasse jamais personne de mort
jamais alors je tiens à dire que yassine
belattar à régis debray il n'est pas du
tout fan de la blague aussi je crois
qu'ils n'ont on travaille plus ensemble
on a travaillé ensemble j'ai travaillé
du tout de la blague et il me l'a dit
aujourd'hui ce qui va il a rien avoir de
nom bien réagi alors tu as tu écris un
tamm écrit un message d'excusés samedi
en premier lieu je tiens à présenter mes
excuses aux familles des attentats et
leurs familles voilà aux victimes des
attentats et leurs familles était ce une
mauvaise blague je crois que cette vanne
était de mauvais goût mais je rassure
tous ceux qui font monter la sauce je ne
souhaite la mort de personne je lancerai
aucun appel à la violence contre
quiconque je ne connais personne pas
personnellement de djihadistes et je
n'ai pas de machine à voyager dans le
temps donc il n'ya pas lieu de faire une
polémique cette blague n'est qu'une
blague est absolument pas un propos
politique et n'a pas lieu d'être prise
comme telle au fait je ne travaille plus
et yassine belattar depuis des mois donc
si vous pouviez ne pas lui faire porter
ce truc sur le dos merci je fais donc de
gros bisous sur le front d'eric zemmour
en espérant calmer son âme au fond ces
mêmes aimons nous les uns les autres
est-ce que tu tues tu en vises et c'est
une forme d' excuses des réponses reçues
règlement ou bien sûr pas du tout
exactement moi j'ai fait une blague on
prend une blague on en fait des propos
politiques en vrai on prendrait des
blagues de pierre doris
humoriste des années 70 ont l'air
prendrait au premier degré aujourd'hui
c'est l'apologie des féminicides alors
est ce que on interdit tout simplement
un type d'humour après c'est autre chose
alors justement c'est différent c'est
vrai qu'elle a fait énormément réagir
vous autour de sa table vous entendez
gaëtan on va voir ce qui va se passer
pour lui et la suite de sa carrière
aujourd'hui il faut savoir que le point
virgule la salle où il joue et a décidé
de doping des programmes et l'hérault et
présentation d'hier et de ce soir face
aux menaces insultes violences verbales
que les équipes du point virgule n'en
subit toute la journée nous allumons
dimanche et lundi le spectacle de gueye
tomatis nous avons condamné sans
ambiguïté sa prise de position notre
métier c'est du plaisir de l'échangé des
rires de la joie il est hors de question
d'exposer des équipes du point virgule
assez déferlement de haine et je
comprends ils ont dû mettre des
policiers ça a été très compliqué
en vrai ils sont fait casser la vitrine
comme ils sont fait agresser ils sont
fait péter les plexi arracher la fiche
n'ont cessé et là donc on avait annulé
deux dates au début et ensuite là on est
obligé de tout annuler alors aujourd'hui
pour la suite de ta carrière c'est même
pu en fait en vrai je vais te dire je
suis pas content d'être là je suis pas
content d'être là dans ce contexte là je
pense que j'ai fait plein d'autres
choses est ce que cette blague est
représentatif de mon travail non est ce
que aujourd'hui
je m'inquiète je m'inquiète de plus
pouvoir jouer en fait je m'inquiète de
parce que j'ai fait une blague sur
quelqu'un qui est dans l'actu je
m'inquiète de plus pouvoir au lieu
d'être ici être dans une salle avec des
gens créer des moments créer du en fait
je pense être un mec plutôt tolérant
dans la vie tu as deux de créer des gens
vident pas forcément que pour les bobos
d'ailleurs parce que on a beaucoup dit
que c'était un bobo islamo-gauchiste
marvel j'aime j'aime les gens j'ai envie
de faire des trucs avec les gens des
blagues et les faire réagir je pense que
bombe à cette blague a fait réagir voilà
c'est là je me sens un peu hâlé jimenez
non mais moi je vous écoute depuis tout
à l'heure et je vous ai en fait vous
entend pas vous vous excusez du tout en
fait vous vous excusez pour je cite un
le merdique ça a fait vous regrettez le
merdier qui vous emmerde en fait auprès
de la personne ont été la france est
parlé par les personnes qui ont pris
cette blague comme étant une blague sur
les victimes des attentats qui n'était
pas une blague sur les victimes des
attentats si j'ai blessé des gens
blessés des familles et je pense que
tout humoriste n'aime pas blesser des
familles nous tout ce qu'on veut c'est
arrivé à faire rire moi j'aimerais même
une règle en humour c'est d'être drôle à
un moment enfin pardon hein donc là vous
dites ça c'est hyper suggère oui mais là
vous dites vous visiblement vu que ça a
créé un émoi c'est que vous n'étiez pas
drôle sinon ça n'aurait pas dû signer la
fin de juin qui m'ont envoyé leur
soutirer qui ont trouvé la blague
marrante oui donc d'accord pas très bien
pourquoi pas comprendre ça va gueuler
clivante est-ce que c'est ma meilleure
blague non pas du tout mais vraiment pas
du tout et encore une fois j'aurais une
machine à remonter le temps je ne la
ferai pas vu le merdy actuel alors vu le
merdier actuelle c'est avec guillaume
moi j'en ai marre de cette époque on
brise des carrières au moindre dérapage
est ce que la blague elle est drôle nom
auquel est maladroite est ce que c'est
une raison pour boycotter complètement
un artiste qui je pense comme beaucoup
d'artistes à une période extrêmement
difficile par decaux vide pendant un an
et demi et briser sa carrière je pense
qu'il faut arrêter parce que tous les
donneurs de leçons à une fois qu'ils ont
donnés leur avis ils rentrent chez eux
ils pensent qu à ça lui c'est lui qui
reçoit des menaces de mort aujourd'hui
c'est lui dont la carrière est en danger
aujourd'hui donc laisser les gens
tranquilles ils humoriste qui tentent
des trucs il prend des risques parfois
l'humour c'est pas forcément drôle il a
essayé de faire une blague il a reconnu
que c'était pas drôle laissez le
tranquille maintenant delphine toi aussi
tu étais non effectivement sortis du
contexte mois au début quand j'ai eu
cette phrase ça m'a choqué maintenant de
vous voir comme ça par les expliquer
tout ça effectivement il ya des
humoristes qui font de l'humour très
populaire une nourrice qui font l'humour
très clivant et de l'humour noir voire
très noir ça c'est très très très très
noir maintenant de la casse est
effectivement votre carrière et tout
c'est pas ça parce qu'il faut bien voir
tout ce que vous avez fait avant et il
ya des choses aussi qui sont limite que
vous avez fait avant pardon alors
ça m'a fait rire un nom alors justement
alors que ma patrie alors justement
parce qu'on va voir c'est tout et on a
ressorti hier sortie ce week-end une
bonne que vous aviez fait qu'on va voir
tout de suite à l'antenne si nordine
veut bien voilà sur sur sa meule pâtit
c'est vrai qu'ils étaient extrêmement
dur hein déjà l'année dernière en
novembre 2020 non mais non s'il vous
plaît voilà merci
une heure c'est maintenant qu'halloween
est passé qui nous sortent le costume de
cm soit ici rex la célèbre jean louis de
limites pour moi celle là pour moi et
beaucoup plus dur que la première ouais
alors chars continuent notamment
d'ailleurs c'est quand même rigolo le
monsieur car tout était ça il y là je
crois qu'il est interdit de droits
civiques
c'est ça mais moi en fait oui ce que
contient un attentat on est censé
laisser un traitement qui est sur
l'émotion et qui nous emmène vers des
discours qui peuvent être des discours
qui vire à l'identitaire à la xénophobie
ou est-ce que nous eûmes orist on a pour
but de mettre des uppercuts la
définition de l'humour selon françois
cabanât de charlie hebdo c'est que
l'humour c'est des grands coups de poing
dans la gueule moi j'ai envie de mettre
des grands coups de poing dans la gueule
à l'heure qu'il est j'ai des mecs qui me
propose de mettre des grands coups de
poing dans la gueule en pensant que
c'est de l'humour il ya une grosse
grosse nuance en vrai si geof ans des
gens avec mes blagues les gens sont pas
obligés de regarder mes blagues à la à
l'heure qu'il est longue on est en train
de proposer des menaces de mort des
appels au suicide de menaces et ma
famille ça n'a plus rien à voir non mais
là où je vous rejoins c'est
effectivement que vous êtes dans une
tradition qui est la tradition hara kiri
c'est-à-dire bêtes et méchants est ténue
chambre c'était la tradition hara kiri
donc moi je suis pas du tout pour votre
boycott et c'est simplement à titre
personnel je n'irai pas voir vos
spectacles parce que
longtemps
et en même temps je vous le dis c'est
pas bon à la limite ce qui me gêne c'est
votre réaction c'est à dire la façon de
que vous avez de vous deux vous
dédouaner en disant c'est vous qui
comprenait pas bien voilà j'ai été
maladroit moi je veux bien convenir à un
moment donné de façon alors il ya eu il
ya deux choses cette blague je pense que
s que encore une fois c'était un
candidat est-ce que c'était réellement
intelligent de la figer sur le net non
ça ne l'était pas est ce qu'il ya une
instrumentalisation qui a été faite de
cette blague à des fins ensuite de virer
un propos humoristiques pour le
transformer en politique ça c'est autre
chose nicolas pernikoff mois bongo
comporteront des anges parce qu'à un
moment donné ce que j'aimerais entendre
c est ce que c'est une mauvaise blague
je suis un gros con je suis nul et voilà
sur sa direct et asseoir la voile à vous
excuser même pas ti pas ti c'est quand
même très limité mais bien sûr emploi
d'eau dit alors je m'excuse j'ai été con
et à ce moment là il ya beaucoup de gens
qui vont vous l'entendre je ne suis pas
juge mais j'ai été extrêmement choqué
quand même beau se faire ce genre de là
à aller plus loin excusez une vague
l'ignoble oui on est sur ce registre est
ce que c'est une blague irresponsable et
un fauteuil j'ai un côté un peu
irresponsable comme j'ai peut-être pas
compris et je le paye aujourd'hui mais
alors vous excusez pas parce que le
problème oui la blague n'est pas très
bonne et puis c'est compliqué parce que
je vais pas pouvoir monter sur scène
machin mais ça moi je m'en fous vous
montiez ou non sur scène que ou que la
salle ne l'a pas fait je suis là coralie
moi ce que j'aimerais savoir c'est
est-ce que vous excusé pour ses propos
qui sont ignobles et encore plus
aujourd'hui ou est-ce que vous ne vous
excusez pas parce que le dcg le problème
de peter vous ne vous excusez pas juste
gaza mais quand on va voir quand on va
voir quelqu'un en spectacle n'a pas sa
place de cyril l'a dit tout à l'heure
vous payez votre place vous faites chier
vous partez tout le monde le sait et du
bad buzz et à l'arrière ça va être vidé
sauf que là le problème c'est que vous
utilisez un médian c'est comme si vous
exprimez télévisions annoncent donc les
gens ils subissent votre chevet ça
avance que je n'ai pas la même chose je
suis pas le premier rue maurice tas ne
pas obtenir un 100 % de réussite sur une
blague je pense que cameron avant moi
bien sûr y arriver et changer ne vous
excusez pas en quoi tu que c'est parce
que
est-ce que je dois m'excuser auprès de
gens qui mangeront et des changements
des gens car on égalerait chaud j'ai ma
famille les joueurs ont été choisis
auprès de l'anglais
totalement différent aujourd'hui est ce
qu'il ya des gens qui ont été offensés
est-ce que c'était intelligent de la
figer sur nan mais vous dites vous
parlez en votre nom il n'y a pas lieu de
faire polémique vous dites chaque fois
là encore des lits d'ehpad machine à
voyager dans le temps donc il n'ya pas
lieu de faire polémique c'est pas à vous
de dire s'il ya lieu ou non venus
aujourd'hui s'il ya lieu de faire
polémique ce n'est pas moi c'est pas à
twitter c'est à la justice de voir si
cette blague a été l'homme que
j'aimerais entendre parler mais
aujourd'hui moi si vous voulez entendre
est-ce que je suis content de cette
blague est ce que je fais ce que je
vient d'anéantir huit ans de travail n'y
avait pas de sam est de rigueur dans le
panneau mais je suis désormais twilight
je vais te dire excuse moi c'est vrai
que voilà en fait ce qui est en train de
dire et je pense que c'est celle à petit
nous on sait qu'il ya beaucoup de gens
qui disent est ce que c'est ce que je
disais tout à l'heure est-ce que tu
t'excuses que tu penses vraiment hâte à
blesser des gens que tu pensais que tu
es de mauvaise note ou bien tu t'excuses
parce que ça fait un bordel derrière qui
fait que ça mais ta carrière en danger
c'est ça le leb et moi j'aime pas
blesser les gens pensent donc sinon ça
que je suis désolé d'en être arrivés à
un point où il ya les gens ont compris
des choses que je ne prêtais pas à cette
blague aujourd'hui est ce que on a un
problème à l'idée de pouvoir faire des
blagues aussi choquantes qu'elles soient
sans devoir affronter un torrent de
menaces je sais plus moi je me suis un
peu préservé je vous le cache pas je
suis monté à 30 milles menaces de mort
donc la non mais je peux pas c'est mon
métier amandine jauger désolé mais moi
j'ai envie de dire dans une tradition
française j'ai envie de me battre pour
questionner les limites de la liberté
d'expression pour questionner l'ambiance
du pays et j'ai envie pouvoir faire des
choses tout simplement mathieu non mais
vous aurez pu mettre fin à tout ça très
rapidement en étant juste assez basique
dans vos excuses écrites lendemain parce
qu'effectivement le lendemain écrire
façon j'ai pas de machine à remonter le
temps laissant entendre que façon
cycling c'est un problème technique et
puis après gros bisou sur le front non
effectivement on est en train d'avoir
l'un des procès les plus les plus
difficiles en ce moment qui existe avec
toutes les familles qui entendent des
témoignages horrible je tenais la main
tout d'un coup la main étaient molles et
froide on entend tout ça plus
effectivement le climat qui est horrible
en ce moment on est sûr on est sûr on
est sur des braises et effectivement
dire aussi que tout plus de moore qui
est à 17% mériterait de mourir dans un
attentat le lendemain il fallait faire
quelque chose de très cash très droit
qui était pardon j'ai des blessés des
gens s'étaient s'était pas drôle et je
suis blessé par ce que j'ai écrit alors
je te fais un but sur le front j'ai pas
de marsan mais entre temps les
stagiaires non mais j'entends le
j'entends le discours parce que sinon je
me sens plutôt sincère d'envoyer dans
votre discours
en vrai je pense que ce qui est
important quand on essaye de faire une
blague c'est même si elle est choquante
de créer un lien avec la personne on est
en train de viser avec cette plaque est
ce que j'ai réussi à créer un lien avec
le public d'eric zemmour je pense pas
donc là je conviens d'un échec sur
s'attaque encore une fois moi j'ai les
boules d'être dans la lumière
aujourd'hui pour cette blague vraiment
je si
j'entends qu'il ya des gens qui que ça
amuse et d'autres qui ont été enterrés
dans cette gamme kia des gens que ça a
mûri et j'ai reçu une multitude de
ensuite je suis désolé donc pour moi
c'est pas forcément compris la blague
moi je me pose la question on a un ami
très proche qui a fait une très mauvaise
blague il en prison en ce moment et il a
vraiment c'est un mec profondément
gentil qui a pas du tout voulu blesser
qui que ce soit mais il a blessé des
gens et même si c'était pas sa volonté
il s'est excusé d'avoir blessé des gens
pourquoi c'est si compliqué de s'excuser
auprès des gens qu'on a blessé pas
auprès des gens qui menacent auprès des
gens qui s'en servent ont été menées ces
braves avaient cessé mais s'il ya des
gens qui sont sincèrement blessés y en a
j'en suis désolé vraiment j'en suis
désolé le problème c'est que le miz moi
je vais sur comme excuse c'est pas chez
moi
moi je veux qu'on arrive à un point
aujourd'hui qui est humoriste ya des
gens qui font de l'humour grand public
il ya des gens qui fait bouillir s'est
pas bien passé donc on s'excuse voilà
vous êtes au boulot vous par exemple
vous êtes boulanger ça vous arrive de
ses excuses et s'est désolé
votre coiffeur il s'excuse le
plateau là se transforme en tribunal par
konami qui es tu pour demander pour
forcer à 100 et c'est vrai j'aime bien
les gens qui je m y paye autre chose
c'est que c'est un humoriste qui
malheureusement pour l'instant n'est pas
très populaire pas très connu si c'était
une star de l'humour moi je vois des
spectacles sur n'explique ce avec des
grands humoristes américains qui font
des blagues sur la pédophilie soit aux
attentats et là c'est génial il ose des
choses il est pas connue dont tout le
monde lui tombe dessus c'est dégueulasse
et la ministre avait demandé des excuses
mais ça c'est aussi pour l'essor de la
situation dans laquelle il répond
l'egypte la boîte une texture et des
gens qui ont fait ça il faut pas que je
viens de vous le dire sérieusement s'il
ya des gens qui sont blessés par mon
travail je suis sincèrement désolé pour
le point de ces que moi j'ai aussi le
droit on est dans un état de droit et
c'est le droit qui prime j'ai le droit
de faire des blagues la maison avec un
moment donné je ne peux gras sous
prétexte que les gens certaines
personnes sauf ans je ne peux pas
arrêter de faire des blagues fabrice
soulier il faut appliquer la règle de
saint thomas d'aquin qui avait été
budgété
l'art du juste milieu à manama et
c'est relativement simple en réalité il
ya tout le monde attend dans cette
affaire vous avez eu tort monsieur parce
que le problème c'est que les blagues
elles sont faites pour être fait en
spectacle une terre que vous êtes en
dizaines ont d'ailleurs fait pour être
se produire en spectacle et donc quand
vous figé sur twitter c'est pas une
blague sur twitter c'est un propos après
chacun est libre de là tu arrives au
second plan ce bien avant la guerre il
est là le problème de fond de court je
viens voir un humoriste je viens voir un
humoriste alors après je me retrouve pas
dans l'humour mais sur twitter hélas on
peut regretter un jamais sur twitter le
problème c'est que vous fige et un
propos qui du coup doit être interprétée
ou non comme une blague il faut
comprendre l'intention avec lequel vous
le faites mais le problème du réseau
social aujourd'hui et de la polémique
fin de la polémique autour du
déclenchement la machine pour le coup
qui s'emballe il ya plus cette subtilité
de l'intention ça c'est le premier choix
je suis pas français nous le fait qu'il
faut figé aussi des excuses comme un
propos son twitter j'y viens jamais sur
le deuxième point où chaque hôte
matthieu delormeau c'est inquiétant mais
s'inquiétant
maximum ça fait deux fois dans la soirée
où chaque passage vers man sur le fait
que en réalité peut-être que ce cas
manquer mais je comprends pourquoi ça
n'a pas été fait parce qu'en fait c'est
très ambigu vous êtes aussi dans une
position qui est ambigu vous savez plus
tellement quoi pensez vous êtes en état
de choc aussi vraiment donné vous prenez
des déferlantes là et vous savez plus
comment réagir mais c'est vrai qu'à un
moment donné la simplicité et sans doute
commandes et de dire ok les gars on
rembobine justement remonte le temps et
que je sais que c'est fini mais je
comprends mais c'est vrai que vous
l'avez fait finalement en libéralisant
un peu le propos c'est vraiment au sens
littéral c'est en venant donner une
littérature à ce propos que l'on est et
ça c'est compliqué à faire mais en
revanche et j'en termine en revanche il
ya un point qui me pose un problème
c'est que dans sur ce plateau on
disserte et la raison sans doute de la
mauvaise blague que vous avez fait alors
qu'il faut quand même se souvenir qu'une
blague un propos sur twitter conduit le
point virgule à être fracasse tient
aujourd'hui sa mission va servir
à faire sur des menaces de mort et les
cimetières du point virgule ont reçu des
menaces de mort
enfin le vrai problème est bien
construit je suis pas totalement
d'accord déjà dans la blague je n'ai pas
fait sur twitter ça fait huit ans que je
fais ça trois ans que j'en vis mon
instinct c'est l'instinct d'un clown mon
facebook c'est le facebook d'un clown je
suis pas philosophe je suis pas
sociologue je suis pas politique c'est
des propos de clown oui mais bienvenue
en enfer manque de jugeote oui
je suis un problème c'est pas vraiment
le problème c'est que vous le faites un
moment donné où il ya un terrible procès
et que du coup on s'est dit qu'il aimait
le faire à ce moment là ça aurait pu
être très bien mûri valenciennois dans
quatre mois bal avec moi j'ai tendance à
écrire sur les actus et en vrai moi je
vous le dis j'ai pas l'habitude d'être
sur les plateaux télé c'est pas c'est
pas l'endroit où je sais j'aime la scène
est en fait mon métier c'est quoi c'est
la liberté d'être con mais là c'est la
liberté de choquer la liberté de heurter
sur cd et la france sur cette major
utiliser ça vraiment tout ce qui a été
dit bah d'abord le mélanger les réseaux
quand les gens viennent te voir dans une
salle ils ont payé sont venus d'eux
mêmes s'ils veulent partir ils partent
on l'a dit et redit moi ce qui me
dérange c'est que toi tu dit eric
zemmour le problème c'est pas eric
zemmour le problème c'est bataclan
mehrez novembre soirée 6 et tous ces
trucs là et la fusion de flammes il faut
que tu comprennes ne plus jamais leur
enfer parce que des gens sont venus sont
morts si vous leur faire tu leur fais
moi t excuse toi je le dis je préfère
que tu assumes quand tout le monde te
demande des excuses moi je n'en demande
pas mais assume fais ce que tu veux tu
vas dans une tempête là tu veux être un
homme tu vas tenir debout parce que là
tu veux tu vas passer un sale quart
d'heure comme merci éric tabard nan mais
c'est vrai
moi voilà c'est juste maintenant juste
les gens ici s'ils ont perdu la vie en
étant heureux ils allaient ou sur des
terrasses pour boire des verres ou boire
les dents des concerts c'est terrible ce
qui s'est passé c'est un traumatisme
c'est terrible c'est fatal mais vraiment
c'est pas laisser ces terribles et de et
de rire d'un truc comme ça et que tu dis
après eric zemmour enlève eric zemmour
c'est pas le problème c'est que ces
jeunes gens là mathieu la blague elle
était fin mai mais relève le relève du
match le truc c'est que les grecs ont
affronté un principe qui s'appelle la
catharsis jouer mais on le droit
d'évacuer aiderait les cper web
juriste faire des
grands mères
est-ce que et là je te pose la question
qui ce que je regarde aussi ce qui se
dit sur twitter il ya des gens aussi ils
disent il a voulu surfer sur le buzz
zemmour et il s'est pris les pieds dans
le tapis forsman pas en vrai cette
blague n'était pas fait en vrai je
rappelle j'ai trois mille follow il ya
eu 50 l'ex était c'est de l'humour de
garage ils ont rappelé les responsables
et sur le dis je twitte commencé parce
que si ça reste quand même des gens qui
l'ont voilà comment 60 allopass et qui a
des gens qui lui envoyer j'aurais voulu
faire le buzz parce que je rassure tout
le monde c'est pas du tout ma volonté
j'aurais voulu faire le buzz j'aurais
tagué regrettez vous ouais j'aurais mis
à acheter eric zemmour s'était pas ça
c'était pour faire marrer des gens qui
aiment bien ce que je fais et c'est tout
je suis pas le mec les bacs à faire
marrer les gens qui t'aiment bien ce
qu'ils font dans ta salle continue à
faire des trucs de sa mère pattie dans
ta salle mais ne mène nous ne nous met
pas dans cette histoire parce que là tu
ne les jeux les gens disent que je ne
mets pas dans mon bain si tu mets dans
mon histoire ce que ça me fait de la
peine mon coach me dit m allez je m'en
fous je n'aime pas charlie hebdo et mais
pas dans son histoire leur groupe dont
je n'achète pas il vient pas dans mes
yeux charlie hebdo faut aller au magasin
faut l'acheter faut que je l'ouvré
c'est plutôt là tu me fais tu me fait
mal parce que je repense à la soirée du
13 novembre je repense où j'étais je
repense aux gens mal on pense aux
pompiers je reprends ce documentaire je
repense à tout tu m'amènes sacs chez moi
j'ai rien demandé mais d'accord
je te demande même pas des excuses mais
en fin d'année il n'y a plus de blagues
quand on mène une blague sur le terrain
de l'émotion c'est le nombre de gens et
ce qu'on pense aux parents du petit
grégory saillard des enfants dans les
années
sur la mort de l'enfant il ya vingt ans
la cession
de 2,2 de temps aussi quand on fait des
blagues et tout ça
je vous dis juste aujourd'hui un
humoriste français qui a la carte je
donne un exemple un nouveau risque un
humour très noir gaspard proust par
exemple il fait la même blague sur son
instar personnes s'en sont offusqués
c'est tout c'est ça la vérité
me lapp à la carte dont tout le monde
lui tombe dessus
tu dis n'importe quoi
sénégas pas le soin des patients elle a
chanté aussi novare soit elle n'en avait
pas et la menace qu'elle est choquante
j'en conviens après essai la baguette tu
admires oubliez ce que je vais non tu as
trouvé dans l'abattoir
là ça fait 48 heures que j'ai pu
tellement heureux
gaëtan tu as peur pour la suite
là j'ai été mis sous surveillance voilà
est-ce que tu as peur pour ta carrière
aussi s'est pas encore une fois non mais
en vrai je serai le mec qui veut une
carrière et tout ça c'est certainement
pas le genre de blague que je ferais moi
j'écris avec ma sensibilité
est ce que dans le climat actuel
c'était une blague qu'on je l'admets
est-ce que ça mérite ce que j'ai mangé
de twitter qu'alimente une des médias
qui réalimente twitter tout part en live
mon adresse fuite je vois des photos de
ces deux mamies en fait il ya vraiment
ça au point virgule qu'on s'attaque au
ps et une admission s'en prennent à d'un
portier pour des plaques vous fait
masser sur la sphère des poncifs la
liberté d'expression mais là
en fait le pire c'est que mon spectacle
ne correspond pas je suis sûr vous
viendriez me voir je suis sûr qu'à la
fin on passera une bonne soirée et vous
auriez vraiment aimé le spectacle est
vraiment je suis dégoûté en vrai je suis
dégouté je suis désolé d'avoir blessé
des gens à croire vraiment bon c'est à
dire actuelle dix n'ont pas bien qu'on
nous nous je vais te dire nous on est
pas on n'est pas pour enfoncer les gens
ici tu te lis je te le dis voilà on
n'est pas là pour ça au contraire on
voulait te recevoir ce soit parce que le
club on a on a vu vraiment ce qui
s'était passé autour de toi et c'est
vrai que la blague elle y je te le dis
moi elle m'a pas fait rire du tout la
blague sur sa mère pattie aime
énormément choqué je te le dis mais on
n'était pas là pour eux on n'est pas là
pour faire un lynchage médiatique
sortie on voulait juste ce soir avoir
ton sentiment savoir si tu regretter
tout ce que tu as fait est juste on
voulait pas voilà que ça prenne des
proportions
soit irréversible et c'est vrai que
quand voilà je sais que tu es voilà tu
as vécu 48 heures très compliqué les
gens qui ont vu ta blague ils ont été
extrêmement choqués mais après voilà il
était important que tu viennes t'excuser
ce soir je pense sur ce plateau ou
ailleurs on a le droit de se calmer
voilà
non mais je te le dis juste voilà il
n'est pas là nous ici pour lyncher les
gens et c'est bien que tennis que tu
pensais que tu ai dit que tu regretter
cette blague s'était dit désolé et c'est
vrai que parfois ça peut prendre des
proportions qui font aussi extrêmement
flipper tout comme voilà c'est la blague
était choquant mais ce qui s'est passé
pour mieux et ans était extrêmement
choquant aussi et je peux vous dire
quand on vous menace votre famille quand
vous avez votre théâtre / dans lequel
vous jouez qui est qui et fracassé ça
peut être aussi très traumatisant la
blague était mauvaise on le sait tous
voila on peut tout se dire la blague
était déjà été choquant ouais mais c'est
vrai que derrière avoir des menaces de
mort et on avoue avoir peur pour sa
famille non mais aussi le fait je pense
mais je suis d'accord pour dire qu'il
était choquant et pas
en revanche
est ce qu'on a le droit de rater une
blague parce qu'un humoriste faut quand
même pas oublier un truc en fait en fait
le droit de garder raté une blague et on
met pas dans ce registre là bas c'était
en fait le truc c'est que la sauce
d'istres là quand tu y vas tu dois être
sûr à son pote sera censé le seul truc
c'est sûr à 100% les notions et bassano
d'initier la télé je suis content
qu'elle va pas rien d'évident moi
j'aimerais moi je te dis moi aussi j'en
ai fait des déterreurs et des conneries
et tu vois et je te le dis je la fais
sur scène les normes conneries moi les
gens ont ri mais je suis dit moi ma la
banque c'est le problème c'est les
points de vue de chacun exactement après
ce que je vais leur faire l'or joue
cependant leur fait plus merci gates en
tout cas d'avoir été là